always know you wanted to be a comedian
some people know very early on and some
people figure it out as you know as a
kid no I wanted to be President
yeah but I did not think I was qualified
yeah it's true though I really I mean
you know I I just did it on a dare
um you know I love it's just really true
I can remember my first joke I can't
stay long in inventory meals yeah what
about like your parents were they
supportive but it what does that mean my
dad like you know I always want you as
soon as you graduate from high school
you're not gonna lay around you know
you're gonna get a job that's on my
dad's side you're gonna get your Louie
you're the laziest person in the world I
go thank you Father
yeah it's not a compliment oh you did
say world she come he goes Andy you did
say world yeah she said my dad used to
do this thing I get up for breakfast and
he would circle the jobs he wanted me to
get unloading trucks digging ditches
finish the Panama Canal and I would go
dad what about this job over here earn
money while you sleep
very funny Louie maybe someday you get a
job where you stand my ground and make
smart remarks
[Laughter]
what's out yes well you know I just
don't think I'm no good at jobs I mean
you know imagine is your waiter hey
there's a bite out of the sandwich I
said you know how far the kitchen is
from here you're lucky there are any
fries on that place
now eat around the bite mark and I'll
bring you half a brownie
[Laughter]
you